- And I love Halloween too,
like it's right up there with Christmas.
I love dressing up, the kids,
I literally have walk-through
haunted houses that I do,
like for the neighborhood.
- Oh I don't do that.
- (laughing) See I get into it.
- The last time I went a haunted house,
I literally, I was throwing
women and children out
of the way to get out.
(laughing)
I was like, I don't like to be scared,
I married the wrong person,
he loves to scare the
crap out of everyone.
(laughing)
(audience laughing)
And I'm like, if you do it,
there's no cuddles for you, for a week.
I hate being scared.
I can't believe you do haunted houses, no.
- They're like, you can
pick your level though.
You can go like, okay I want a level one,
- Okay, I want Candyland.
- Kids can do it.
- Actually,
that would by creepy.
- Oh, that's a good theme.
No, I like it.
- That might be creepy.
Like scary Candyland.
We're onto something here.
- I kinda love it.
I think you came up with a great plan.
- I know!
We're gonna do this.
But also, here's the
big news also as well.
Your Vegas residency at Planet
Hollywood was just extended
(audience cheering)
through 2020.
(audience applauding)
What do you love, 'cause
everybody's doing a Vegas,
so what do you love about it?
- The experience.
You have to come, bring
a fun group of people,
'cause I love feeding off the energy,
but it's a great environment.
It's a great place to be
expressive and creative and,
you know, I feel at home
most when I'm onstage,
and it's a five sensory experience.
So, you can smell, taste,
obviously hear--
- It's like that ride!
(laughing)
- You know that ride that, what is it?
- Soarin' Over California?
- Soaring!
Yes! I love that ride!
- Yes!
I love it.
- And you smell, like, jasmine?
- Yes, yes!
I actually, it's so
funny you said, we, mm.
- We're, I know, I also
have a snowglobe idea.
I want to do a Christmas show in Vegas.
I want it all to be a snowglobe,
and we're gonna create my whole world.
So we're so similar.
- Oh my god, you should come,
and we should sing a song in Vegas.
- Okay! That makes me nervous!
(audience cheering)
(laughing)
- [Guest] Yes!
- [Host] I would love to!
Do you have any crazy,
'cause this is the thing my
husband and I try and do,
'cause we have four kids,
and it's like fun to just be an adult,
like a fun adult again,
and have like a night
with your ladies or
your friends, whatever.
And so, do you have any
wild, fun nights in Vegas?
- All the good ones I'm proud
to have minimal memory of,
but... (laughs)
(laughs)
I mean, it's Vegas, right?
No.
I like to go out with my, like, crew.
Like my, dancers are so fun
to go out with, aren't they?
Like your band, your dancers.
- Oh my gosh, or not,
'cause then you feel stupid.
'Cause you're like, "Yeah, you look great!
"No, I'm not going to join you."
- No, I kinda like let them,
but they're entertaining,
they're just like,
they're just like--
- Yeah, my band's like that.
Yeah, my band's like that.
They're all cool.
- Yes, your band, you know.